it's a turkey not a tiger
yeah it's gonna scratch do you have you
seen have you hunted turkey before
i want the gloves and the nut though is
what i'm saying because when i go in
there i want to be able to like get it
it's a turkey not a tiger
yeah it's gonna scratch do you have you
seen have you hunted turkey before
to be honest i don't really know what to
do afterwards though no i'm just saying
like once we catch it i'm saying like do
we just release it
it came through
broke the window completely out that's
what i was called i don't know turkey's
gonna be kind of gnarly sometimes birds
are scary let's see what we got here
i see it
how big is it uh it's
i think it's doable
oh yeah it's walking around tom so
that's good
oh god
all right uh did you just go in at it
what are you hiding over there foreign
yeah we needed two of these brady
[Music]
well done all right now i just don't
know okay
how far down
i mean we're on the second floor
it's trying it's probably not mega
suitable to just uh i got him hold on
brady hold on to this
all right let's go inside
okay
we got her
that's what you get for asking for the
net
let her
there you go hold on